ça fait longtemps qu'on ne vous avait
présenté un sapin de la semaine cette
fois ci ce sont des entrepreneurs qui
nous ont écrit à propos encore une fois
d'un annuaire d'entreprise en ligne
ils ont reçu cette lettre disant pas
venir du portail des entreprises du
canada qui leur demande de mettre à jour
leur donner encore une fois on se donne
des airs officielle avec une antenne où
le gouvernemental
on n'a plus qu'à signer pour confirmer
que les informations sont valides
si ce que certains ont fait mais en
lisant la lettre plus attentivement on
voit bien que quelque chose cloche
on écrit que le service est gratuit puis
trois lignes plus bas
on nous dit que cette inscription est
payante en renvoyant un formulaire signé
vous vous engagez en fait à verser un
montant de 1000 367 $ par année à un
éditeur allemand par la suite ceux qui
ont signé le contrat reçoivent une
facture des rappels plus en plus
insistants et même des menaces de
poursuites judiciaires
le problème ici c'est que bien des gens
sont intimidés par ce genre de menaces
ce qui est un peu normal et il paye
nous avons découvert que cette arnaque
originaire d'allemagne ne touche pas que
le canada en fait il y à des portails
des entreprises dans plusieurs pays et
les sites sont pratiquement tous
identiques et tous bidon si vous avez
envoyé le formulaire que vous recevez
une facture vous demandant de payer
vous pouvez envoyer une lettre
enregistrée disant que vous refusez de
payer mais si vous avez déjà payé
rapporté votre corps au centre
antifraude
[Musique]